so once again one Championship delivers
I saw this entire card it was insane
dude the MU all mu Thai card it's the
highest level Muay Thai and they have 4
o gloves on so if you're ready for some
Knockouts this is your it's crazy dud
ready for this the first this is the
main card seven out of eight fights on
the card where starts Knockouts and then
the one fight our boy Joe which was fun
as hell so fun with the unanimous
decision seven out of eight knock dude D
were getting stared and it's not just
heavyweights you know when you see an
all heavyweight card like yeah of course
that's what it is uh flyweights there's
a 120b dude that got dropped with a body
shot the 150b dude just KO Central dude
insane and how big is that Roman cat
that Swedish monster 6 seven god dog SC
and he fast as hell like that was great
man it was so much fun to watch